Its fun to look at these old pictures once you know what they mean
y'know? at-at least that's what i come to understand
Once I kinda understand the
the underlying rationale for, i mean someone worked hard
on that, that's an engraving right? they took a long time making that picture
they're serious about it.
When you understand what it means
You know, all those people the-there
they're prostrate
at the revelation of the law, it's like well no wonder
It's like break the law! and see what happens
Break the Universal Moral Law man, and see what happens
you know i see people in that situation, well as you all do, all the time
Perhaps me more than you because I'm a clinical psychologist, y'know.
if the people I've seen haven't broken the Universal law
then you can bloody be sure the people around them have
It's No Joke! like you make a mistake and things
will go seriously wrong for you!
and so...it's no wonder you've been
Terrified
of the revelation of the structure that governs our being
one of the things that is so remarkable about the New Testament is that
this is a other thing Nietzsche commented on.
he was a real admirer of the Old Testament
Not so much of the New Testament
It was a sin for Europe to have glued the New Testament
onto the Old Testament,
'cause he thought the Old testament was a really accurate representation
of the phenomenology of being, its like (points finger up)
Stay Awake, speak properly
Be honest, or watch the Hell out!
Because things will come your way,
that you do just not want to see at all! And it might not just be you.
It might be everyone you know
and everything about your culture, that is demolished for
for generations after generations
Stay awake and be careful
And I think people only dont believe that when
they're being Hubristic
and i think that most people know that deep in their hearts, y'know
when you get high on your horse, that happens fairly often
If you have any sense, you'd think.. Jeez, well i'd better  be careful
tap myself down a fair bit.
Because if I get too puffed up man somethings gonna come along
and take me out at the knees. And everyone knows that
Pride comes before a fall. Its like, if you have any-
that's why it says in the Old Testament
That the Fear of God is the Beginning of Wisdom
Its like, I've never in all my years as a clinical psychologist
And this is something that really does terrify me
I have never seen anyone ever get away with
anything at all, even once.
y'know theres that old Idea that God has a book, y'know? and
Keeps track of everything in Heaven, it's like okay, okay
Maybe its not a Book.
But that is a really useful thing to think about because,
and well maybe you disagree, and think that people get away with things all the time. well
I tell I've never seen it, what I see instead is that,
Thing happens, right? Someone twists the Fabric of reality.
And
they do it successfully because it doesn't snap back at them that moment.
And then like two years later, something unravels
and they get walloped, and they think, 'oh my god that's so unfair!'
And then we track it, it like well what happened before that and this?
Oh, oh this! Thats where it went wrong
Its this, because you can't twist the fabric of reality
without having it snap back at you
It doesn't work that way, and why would it?
Because what're'ye going to do? Twist the Fabric of reality? I don't think so
I think its bigger than you, and i think that one of the things that
really tempts people was the Idea that
'well i can get away with it' Its like, Yeah you try
see how well that works, its like you get away with
Nothing!
And that is the beginning of wisdom,
and its something that deeply terrifies me
Ever since last september (2017) when
i've come to a broader public attention One of the things
i've been terrified of making a mistake, because i certainly know im  more then capable
of making a mistake, and thank God so far either
I've haven't made one or no ones found out about it
So, but its like y'know
we walk on a very thin and narrow edge
and we're very lucky when things aren't degenerating
into chaos or
rapidly moving to far too much order.
And its not a easy thing to stay on that line
and you can tell when you stand on that line
because things are deeply meaningful and engaging when you're on that line But if you're not existentially terrified
about the consequences of wavering off that
you are truly not awake!
and that's what I see in this picture
look out, man! Because there are rules and if you break them
god help you.